let me just block out this corner that
you look really you look like you're
trying to block out the corner you want
to talk about your personal stuff is
that what it is
[Laughter]
that's jennifer lopez poking fun at
today show host hoda cotby
why well seemed like she was giving hoda
a taste of her own medicine you want to
talk about your personal stuff
of course jen is referring to hoda's
recent split from fiance joel schiffman
which she announced on monday we decided
that we're better
as friends and parents
than we are as an engaged couple
fast forward to thursday's show and jlo
flips the script on hoda when the news
anchor tries to cover up a headline
about her breakup let me just block out
this corner you look really you look
[Laughter]
during the interview hoda and her fellow
today show anchor savannah guthrie chat
with the triple threat who's promoting
her new film marry me
all right let's do it again
marry me
jlo opens up about the obvious
similarities between her character in
the movie and who she is in real life
like i know what it feels like to go
home and have them like
making jokes about you
yes yes because i feel vulnerable i know
what that is
you know you guys are like in the
spotlight as well and that's when the tv
personalities start asking jen about her
recently rekindled romance with ben
affleck i feel like we're talking around
it it's like people want to know because
obviously there are a lot of parallels
and you're back together with ben
affleck and a lot of people were rooting
for that relationship back then i know
this is like you don't want to
necessarily like spill your guts about
something that's personal and it belongs
to you but i think so many people can
relate to like oh the one that got away
or the one you always wondered about or
what if like how did you
find each other again i think you know
we can talk about that backstage if you
really want to know
something jen's recognized with this
second chance at love the importance of
privacy i think what we learned from the
last time is that
love when you are lucky enough to find
it is
so sacred and special and you have to
hold a little bit of that privately
and uh and and that's what we've learned
but we're very happy if that's what
you're wondering
while the couple has done plenty to
avoid publicly talking about their
relationship that's made things for
their famous friends a bit difficult
like ben's bff matt damon how did you
even know that that benefit was a thing
again possibly maybe i just heard you
guys i was sitting here waiting to come
on tv it's the first thing i this first
time i heard about it and what did you
think i didn't uh yeah
that's a fascinating story
all right let them out
true i love them both i hope it's true
that would be awesome yeah i just
literally really gave him our dime no we
said we just we just said we just where
did we stand so bad for him i was like
oh my god
thankfully matt is a good sport and told
e.t he loves benefit 2.0 that was great
it's it's wonderful and uh i'm just
happy to see uh see my friend really
happy as for ben and jen's future well
seems they'll be taking a page out of
her latest rom-com by heading down the
aisle last month the source told et that
the couple is madly in love and their
friends think they may be tying the knot
sooner than later quote it's only a
matter of time
[Music]